thank you very much Dean 3 president
Bollinger mr. Goldman mrs. maleman
ladies and gentlemen I want to thank the
faculty and staff the students who are
graduating for giving me a chance to
share this special day I think the
family and friends who are here who
helped the students I'd like to begin by
expressing my personal profound
appreciation to the mailman school for
four reasons first of all you gave me a
chance to come see my daughter get a
degree secondly Dean preached
predecessor dr. Alan rosenfield helped
me to established our hiv/aids program
around the world and without the
invaluable assistance of the mailman
school I'm not sure we could have gotten
up and going thirdly thank you very much
I became friends with dr. Rosen field
and I watched him handled ALS disease
which is affected other friends of mine
and family members of some of my closest
friends and I never saw a man handled
his impending end of life with more
dignity or make more out of the life
that he had left and
finally I am very grateful to you for
the work that people from the mainland
school did in Haiti immediately after
the earthquake and continue to do their
for mental health cell protection and
the long term rebuilding of the health
care system I thank all the graduates
for your commitment to doing public
health work how public health issues are
resolved or left unresolved will shape
much of the 21st century and I want to
make five simple points today first the
obvious one represented by you the
interdependent world of the 21st century
is a fascinating place it is more
diverse than ever before as the crowded
tests there's more access to more
information more quickly than ever
before there are more scientific and
technological advances coming at us than
ever before most interesting one
recently has been the finding in the
treasure trove of genome studies that
between one and four percent of our
genetic makeup was contributed by
Neanderthals and our pre-human ancestors
I keep wondering if that will excuse
every mistake I made going back to my
fourth birthday I can only say that I
was delighted that women as well as men
have Neanderthal genes otherwise the
late-night comics would have fodder for
decades to come the second point I want
to make is
that for all of its joys this world has
a lot of challenges as we all know the
benefits of the modern world fall
unevenly among countries and within
countries and people handle being on the
short end of the benefits in different
ways I've said in other places and I
might as well say here I think a lot of
the wackiest things that are happening
in American politics today really
reflect a cry of despair from people who
just want all this change to stop so
they can find some solid ground to stand
on Virginia for example has terrible
budget problems so when the governor of
Virginia issued that Proclamation to
bring back Confederacy month and didn't
mention slavery until Prada to do so I
don't think he suddenly became more
racist I think he was responding to all
those people who feel that they have no
solid ground to stand on and so they're
saying stop the world I want to get off
I want to go back to some time when I
was in control of something the problem
with that approach is you can't stop the
world and you can't get off and so we
have to look honestly at what the
challenges are essentially they fall I
believe into three categories the world
is too unequal it is too unstable and it
is completely unsustainable because of
the way we produce and consume energy
and all of those have serious public
health implications if you look at
inequality has the world's people live
on less than two dollars a day before
the earthquake more than seventy percent
of Haitians who are living on less than
two dollars a day but there are massive
public health implications a billion
people have no access to clean water 2.6
billion people have no axe
that's the sanitation a billion people
go to bed hungry every night before the
earthquake Haiti had no national health
system there was an interesting article
in the press this week as you might
imagine I get all the clips worldwide on
Haiti and read them every day about how
some people are actually getting better
health care now from the makeshift
hospitals that people like you have gone
down to set up than they were before the
quake but there are still massive public
health problems there with the rainy
season coming on even if no hurricane
hits a tent city and blows it down and
damages people there will be puddles of
water everywhere in a place that has no
adequate sanitation and every boy or
girl with a cut on his or her foot who
steps in a puddle of water is at risk of
contracting a waterborne disease one in
four of all deaths on earth every year
come from AIDS tuberculosis malaria and
infections related diseases related to
dirty water eighty percent of the people
in the last category are children five
and under and I worry about it every day
when the earthquake hit Haiti 87 metric
tons of food had been pre-positioned in
El Salvador because the Caribbean is
both a hurricane center and an
earthquake action area and the world
prepared for that and that food was a
godsend in the beginning I don't know
what would have done without him but I
found very quickly that there was no
such reserve of sanitation equipment and
no reserve production capacity so we
emailed every producer of compost
toilets and other sanitation traditional
sanitation field in the world and paid
for everything we could pay for and got
everything we could give there as quick
as we could and there's
wasn't enough and so now there may be a
second wave of tragedies in Haiti
because of the inequalities of the
modern world in healthcare the world you
live in is highly unstable you see it in
the financial crisis which began here
spread to Europe spread to Asia hurt our
friends in Latin America you see it now
with the problems of Greece imperiling
the European Union and very idea of the
common currency and now the Federal
Reserve has opened a line of credit for
European countries because the American
stock market is being held down by fears
that the contagion could spread here
from tiny Greece part of big Europe part
of the big world but you also saw it
when the sars epidemic started on
mainland China has spread to Hong Kong
turns up into rubble and all the perils
associated with swine flu which thank
God didn't fully materialize partly
because everybody worked so hard on it
but cases show up in Mexico and they
close the Fort Worth school district for
several weeks we had a case diagnosed in
New York and total strangers would come
up to Hillary me on the weekends we were
walking in Chappaqua New York asking if
they could still take their kids to a
Broadway play so the instability of the
modern world is manifest in healthcare
too and in many other ways that you all
know and the unsustainability of climate
change has enormous public health
implications if the worst calculations
proved right and we don't reduce our
greenhouse gases by enough quickly
enough it's estimated it by 2050 we'll
have to move at least a hundred million
people away from coastal cities will
lose 50 feet of Manhattan Island okay
here we're in
well the island in us will only use 50
feet around there'll be vast changes in
food production patterns with
unpredictable consequences more drying
up of fresh water sources when we've
already got a billion people without
access to fresh water and already you
see it in the changes going on in
Australia ironically the next hardest
countries to be hit according to the
climate models will be countries least
able to handle it including Afghanistan
and Haiti and sub-saharan Africa and
there are evident consequences now last
year for the first time in history more
fish was consumed which was grown by
fish farmers than which were found
naturally in the oceans rivers and lakes
of the world why because the oceans are
partly because they are overfished and
partly because increasingly the chemical
content of the ocean is changing as they
bravely absorb more carbon dioxide and
are therefore less able to support large
fish populations and we have no idea
often what these fish that are farmed or
being fed all of which will have
enormous implications in the future so
if you're in the public health business
you have to ask yourself what are the
public health consequences of inequality
and instability and unsustainability and
what is the response is it changing a
government policy changing personal
behavior or changing the nature of
healthcare delivery the next point I
want to make
is that the problems of the modern world
are fundamentally different in poor and
rich countries in poor countries the
problem essentially boils down to this
it's a problem of capacity of systems
there are many different life stories in
this class and that what's many of you
had to overcome great obstacles to get
where you are I'm sure several members
of this class are the first person in
your family's ever to get a degree
nonetheless you did have access to
systems that brought you to these chairs
today and many of them you take for
granted you'd be shocked that the air
conditioning went off for the lights
failed of the microphone failed and you
couldn't hear a word I'm saying you just
take it for granted much of the work I
do now is in places in the world where
people can take none of this for granted
where people every bit as smart as you
we're willing to work as hard as you
have have no predictable beneficial
consequence from the acts they take in
those places the work of Public Health
is system building so that there are
predictable consequences to constructive
efforts and in Haiti what we're trying
to do is not in health care we're not
trying to build back better in education
we're not trying to build back better
we're really trying to build well for
the very first time they have never had
a health care system even though they
have two of the finest NGO public health
efforts in the world Partners in Health
headed by dr. Paul Farmer and guess keo
headed by dr. bill pap which is the
oldest AIDS clinic in the world outside
the United States but they've never
really had a national health system
partners in health and our foundation
work to build one for the first time
rwanda and they now have first-class
hospitals in every region of the country
satellite clinics and community health
workers trying to go into every village
in the country we're trying to do the
same thing in Malawi in the Sutra now
that's what we have to do in Haiti and
in many other places throughout the
world President Obama and the Secretary
of State had advocated that America
changed the focus of its aid program to
try to help other countries do this it's
really important my foundation has more
than a hundred people work in Ethiopia
now because nobody in Ethiopia is going
to die of AIDS because of the
unavailability of medicine or because
the money is not there to pay for it but
they are going to die of AIDS because
the country has 80 million people and 58
million of them live in sixty thousand
villages of a thousand or less and when
we began there were only seven hundred
clinics for those sixty thousand
villages so they figured the Ethiopians
if they build 3,500 everybody will at
least be within a day's walk of the
clinic and if they have AIDS or
tuberculosis and malaria at least they
can be kept alive if there the women are
pregnant at least they can get some
basic maternal care this is important
they have to build the systems now in
the wealthy countries the problems are
just the reverse we have systems that's
how we grew rich our problems are that
the system's become impervious to change
they become too rigid people gain a
greater interest in preserving their
position within the system and advancing
the purpose for which the system was
created in the first place and that's
why it was so hard for so long to get
health care reform in America I mean
we're spending 17.2 percent of gdp on
health care to ensure eighty-four
percent of the people none of our
wealthy competitor spends more than ten
and a half
of Switzerland at 11 i have but they're
an older population in remote alpine
villages of the extremely expensive
delivery system but all the other major
countries are between nine and ten and a
half percent of gdp that means we spend
a trillion dollars more on health care
than we would spend if we had any other
country system so some of the people
getting the trillion dollars wanted in
theory to ensure one hundred percent of
the people but in practice there was
always something wrong with whatever
plan was proposed which is why I'm very
glad that we adopted the health care
reform bill even though it isn't perfect
and the work has just begun but the
truth is we had to keep changing and
public health will have a lot to say
about that one of the good things about
to build that almost nobody knows is
that senator Sanders got about ten
billion dollars in there to expand
public health clinics what are they
going to do are they going to treat the
people who still won't have insurance
they're going to treat the immigrants
who are here who won't be in the system
can they do more to provide preventive
and primary care at affordable prices to
people who want to buy insurance should
they be able to buy into some plan that
the public health clinics will offer
somebody should be thinking about this
it's a public health issue that can
change the rigidity of the system look
at the obesity problem in Americans
number one public health problem in the
country and interestingly enough it is a
problem of prosperity that affects
overwhelmingly the unprocessed as
obesity is on the other side of knife
edge the knife edge of hunger and it
becomes a problem in every country that
develops an urbanized middle class it's
a big problem in India now there are
more people dying of heart attacks
strokes and cancer
in India then aged the UK and Ireland
have national campaigns against
childhood obesity huge public health
problem because it is a reflection of
what we eat whether we exercise the
working patterns of parents how much
time they have to buy and prepare food
what kind of food they can afford and in
the case of the United States and some
place in other places it's also a
function of how we produce and market
food these are enormous public health
issues the estimate is that obesity
alone already adds a 150 billion dollars
a year to America's health care bill I
think that's quite conservative I can't
prove it but I think it's a lot more so
we do a lot of work on this my
foundation has made an agreement with
the soft-drink people that will has
reduced by eighty eight percent to
caloric content of drinks sold in public
schools in America it's just the
beginning but we have to re-examine this
issue and it may be that the way we
produce and market our food will have to
change it's a public health issue that
can't be dealt with solely with a
treatment response and there are lots of
other examples like this but I think the
way we pay for medicine is a public
health issue if we pay for procedure
instead of for overall care and wellness
will get more procedures whether we get
more wellness or not and we'll run the
bill up all of these things require a
public health response
now besides the problems of poor
countries in the problems of rich
countries there is the whole issue of
how they relate to each other and what
they do the Global Fund on AIDS TB and
malaria the PEPFAR program started under
President Bush these were great public
health responses but how we do this
really matters and we're reaching a
crisis now I'm worried about the eighth
effort for the first time in a decade
because the economic crisis means the
Global Fund is underfunded so far this
year the United States was asked by
countries all over the world to spend
more money on building out health
systems so you deal with maternal and
child health issues other basic health
issues but with the budget caps that
they got it leaves less money to
increase the PEPFAR program for AIDS and
malaria and the Gates Foundation which
has helped my foundation a lot in
subsidizing artemisinin-based malaria
drugs in 11 countries in Africa and I
have talked a lot about how we can make
the money go further change the delivery
system these are serious public health
problems Uganda has already had to stop
taking new aids patients think about
that they're now four or five million
people that I keep getting different
numbers on antiretrovirals in the
developing world our foundation
negotiated low-cost contracts that serve
about half of them including two-thirds
of all the kids but what happens when
you're running a country and you're
treating 300,000 people and the three
hundred and first thousand person that
shows up is turned away in an effect
given an end of life sentence how are we
going to deal with this what would you
do it's a public health issue how about
the way
we give food aid there's still a lot of
hunger in the world and in the United
States and we have record use of food
stamps record use of the food banks food
banks are out of food in America but
think about the way we give food aid in
the United States we still say that
except in an absolute emergency the food
that we give has to be grown in the
United States and shipped on American
flag ship we were giving food to Haiti
for example grown not in the Dominican
Republic but grown in the United States
Canada had the same rule and a few years
ago they started giving half their aid
from food into place closest to the
family or the hunger which meant the
money went further the food got there
quicker and you supported local
agriculture and a more sustainable food
environment we ought to do that in all
the differences i have with president
bush that's one thing that i agreed and
with him on and we were virtually alone
in the Republican and the Democratic
Party nobody in Congress would help us
because they were afraid of the farm
lobby we can afford this and our farmers
can afford this we have a good torrent
support program we don't need to do this
we could save fifty thousand more lives
every year just by changing the way we
give due date that's a public health
issue and it's something you ought to be
heard on we need the thinking of people
who understand public health as we make
these excruciating ly difficult
decisions about whether to build out a
health care network or buy more medicine
and keep in mind when you build out the
healthcare network you're going to have
even greater demand for the medicine why
I have the prevention programs in so
much of the developing world failed when
it comes to AIDS and can anything be
done to make them more effective there's
plenty of money being spent trying to
develop an AIDS vaccine or a cure but
we're still not there yet
and until we get there we have to think
about this finally there are lots of
other issues that affect multinational
development clean water how much of our
age should be given and clean water and
shouldn't it be considered a public
health issue shouldn't we think about
the energy policies we support in other
countries in terms of air quality
whether people are burning kerosene and
small Hut's in developing countries are
belching coal and old-fashioned
generators when in much of the
developing world it is sunny and hot and
windy while we're trying to put up more
solar panels and solar thermal
facilities and windmills in America
shouldn't there be an aggressive effort
to give that to other people Hillary
announced the other day that the United
States was going to try to do something
to help the Caribbean become more
self-sufficient in energy because our
neighbors there have the highest
electric rates in the world because they
have to import all their energy
virtually every island in the Caribbean
could be completely self-sufficient with
solar and wind shouldn't we be doing
that for public health reasons as well
as for economic reasons these are the
kinds of connections that you will have
to make in your lifetime if you want the
world to work for more people the final
point I want to make is this
whether you go into the private sector
or work for a public agency here or
another country or an international
agency or you work for an NGO you will
do public health because there is public
health and all of these things we have
discussed and everything you do should
be put through the filter that I
mentioned is it integrating the world
are disintegrating the world is it
promoting the positive forces of
interdependence health education
well-being are the negative ones in a
quantity instability unsustainability if
it's doing the former it's good if it's
doing the latter it's not the world your
children and grandchildren will live in
will be determined by your success in
reducing the positive the negative and
building up the positive forces of our
interdependence public health is at the
core of every single chromatic issue one
final point on the genome when we
finished sequencing it with the
expenditure a lot of your tax money in
2000 as a political person the thing I
found most interesting was the initial
conclusion that from a genomic
standpoint we're all ninety-nine point
nine percent the same and then craig
Venter did another study and said oh
hold it we're not we're only 99.5
percent the same now all of you know
with three billion elements in the
genome four tenths of one percent is a
significant number but from a social
political and philosophical point of
view it's not very much it means if you
look around this crowd every single
difference you can see from the color of
your skin to the color of your eyes to
the shape of your body to your gender
every non age-related difference you can
see
is rooted in somewhere between one tenth
of one percent and five tenths of one
percent of your whole biological being
and yet everybody spends ninety percent
of time worried about the one tenth of
one percent now my position is in the
world you're living in since you can't
stop it you can't get off and you can't
put up walls again we need to spend a
lot more time we're at about two
ninety-nine point nine percent we need
to understand it the only way we can
appreciate celebrate and enhance the
impact of our diversity what is special
about us is to always always believed
that our common humanity matters more if
we do we'll have good public health
policies and if we do you will live in
the most interesting prosperous peaceful
exciting time in human history and every
one of you carries some portion of
responsibility to make that happen thank
you very much
you